foreign
[Music]
Chiefs game we had them in the crowd
um really doing pre-game really walking
around you know checking out barbecue
and and doing all type of stuff I'm
pretty excited to see what the fans
saying if the Bell seems
Buffalo Bills baby this is what we do
headbands
don't you worry by the Black Eyed Peas
[Music]
everything's gonna be all right New York
by a boogie I'm from New York they just
gotta represent only team from the New
York baby some Coolio Gangsters Paradise
as I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death R.I.P Sexy Back by
Justin Timberlake
Victory cause all we do is win
that was dope man what would I add to
the playlist
um
I'm a huge Phil Collins guy like
I love in the area tonight like
you know they already had like the
Buffalo Bills already had like their
style of music you know um in the locker
room before games and stuff and I didn't
want to change that
but I had to have them play
Phil Collins In the Air Tonight
um right when we come in and said when
we go out for like pregame and stuff
when we warm up and we warm up as you
know a team and then we go back in the
locker room right when we go back in the
locker room
is blasting as loud as it can be home
and away games it's it's the it's Phil
Collins and we started off from we
started off at the very first position
of the song and it goes all the way
through then the drums drop and I'm
really just like what he's talking about
like
you know I've been we've been waiting
for this moment you know our whole
entire life like you know the front
office here with the Buffalo Bills
um you know Bill's Mafia this this
community here in Buffalo like they've
been waiting for a Super Bowl team like
they're that the whole history of the
franchise right and
when you hear Phil Collins say I've been
waiting for this this moment my whole
life like and you got your pads on and
you putting your tape on and you just
getting ready for the game like it
really it really helps me put you know
the moment into perspective it really
helps with my mindset going into any
game it could be hot cold uh home away
it just it just puts me in this in this
special mode that that I need to be in
and go out there and play to play to go
out there and play to the best of my
ability
um you know I listen to a lot of music
it changes you know I like to listen to
future but I always have to have
Phil Collins In the Air Tonight before
each and every game that's not only with
the bills but I we had it I had them do
it at the Rams and of course throughout
my Broncos career and what Texas A M but
I got another question from you know our
fan let me see it my name is Taryn
Taylor I'm actually from Kansas City my
dad's from Buffalo if you could have an
Olympic-sized swimming pool full of
anything what
if I had an Olympic-sized swimming pool
and I could feel it with anything what
would I fill it with
I mean it's a
I should tell Court this I wouldn't say
it's tough because
you know some it just depends on what
I'm doing with this food like of course
if I was partying like you want to have
some type of alcoholic drinking it that
you could just go drink and you got to
have it chill and you can have it ready
to go you know and you have an olympic
size you know whatever that may be but
you know I'm thinking more of the
recovery tip if I had an Olympic-sized
swimming pool and I could feel it with
anything I would say I would fill it up
with heavy
Epsom salt
heavy heavy Epsom salt and I don't want
it to be heated I want I wanted to have
so much epsom salt in there that when I
get in there like I kind of I just float
on the Epsom salt
um I'm a big fan of Epsom salt baths
they bring me back each and every week
um
like I don't know I don't know where I
would be without Epsom salt baths with a
little bit of hydrogen peroxide and
alcohol in there we got another question
let me see
I like this Mount Rochester New York Bob
Miller we're so happy you love being
here in the Buffalo what do you love
most about Buffalo
what is my favorite thing about Buffalo
honestly
this is my favorite and least favorite
thing about Buffalo
let me explain
the food here
is amazing
the food here is amazing from
Wings Italian food Caribbean food and
Caribbean food is my favorite food like
oxtails beans and rice
um stewed chicken like all of that stuff
they got they got great Caribbean food
here
um
they got great pizza here they got a
little bit of of great everything except
healthy food you know in La when you're
L.A you can go find like healthy food
like you got Erawan and you know all of
these healthy places to eat but here in
Buffalo you don't have none of that you
just got good Wings good pizza good
Caribbean food good Italian food
and
when you're sitting around doing a
podcast all day or playing Call of Duty
or going to play golf like
it can just like sit on you so my
favorite thing about Buffalo is the food
and my least favorite thing about
Buffalo is is the food because it is a
struggle for me each and every week to
make weight
um each and every week I gotta find some
type of way to to cut the weight down
and I often just find myself just like
you know really just cutting the meals
completely out of my day and just having
like a protein shake
um to really make that weight because
you know I can't go into the game super
heavy because when I start getting heavy
when I start getting over
254 pounds like this is my I've been
I've been playing football my whole
entire life I'm like a Ferrari right and
when you start putting like weight in
the trunk or like wait in the back seat
I feel that
and whenever I get over like you know
254 pounds 256 pounds like I started
feeling in my knees and my ankles and my
joints I like to play between 246 and
252 254 like right in right in between
that area is good for me so Buffalo it
that the food is is uh one of my
favorite things about this place and in
the food here is one of my least
favorite things you know this week
we have a really really tough
Jets team we're going to new we're going
to New York City to play these guys
we're really New Jersey
um I played the Jets last year they were
a different team than what they what
they are now
um they have a they got sauce Gardener
and he can win the game by himself I'm a
huge fan of sauce Gardener you know I
follow him on Twitch he's a gamer too
he's a gamer just like me and um you
know we got out we got a big time
cornerback too with career Elam you know
this would be the battle of the first
round uh cornerbacks this week and I'm
excited to see my guy Kyer go I'm
excited to see sauce Garden to go sauce
Gardener is six six three can can move
like you know he's a nickel
huge fan of sauce gardener
um and I'm excited to you know this I'm
excited for this game man I love playing
MetLife Stadium
um I I played the Jets there one time
before I'm excited man I'm excited to go
to uh to New Jersey man and play the
Jets
um they they lost a tough game uh to the
Patriots and you always gonna get you're
always gonna get a team team's best
fresh after a loss you want you want
them to win and blow guys out and then
you know they let their guard down a
little bit whenever we play them but we
gonna get their best you know it's been
a lot said about Zach Wilson I'm a huge
fan of Zach Wilson
um I was a huge fan of him at BYU he
kind of reminded me of Patrick Mahomes
but I'm not in the comparisons
they are they are two totally different
players I'm just saying the stuff that
he was doing with uh BYU running around
and throwing the ball like you know I I
you know you know I was a fan of that I
mean I'm a fan of exciting players
coming to the league just like Zach
Wilson we need to win this one we need
to win this game it's going to be a hard
Fire game we need it two AFC East losses
you know we don't want to put ourselves
there I'm not even going to talk about
that man because we're going to play a
great game versus a really good team and
division teams you you prepare for these
games differently because you see these
guys twice a year so you kind of know
what they're going to do you they kind
of know what you're gonna do and it's
just it's football man and I always like
these these divisional games man so
it'll be a good win in New York they're
gonna be like a harness Nest riled up
ready to go man and I'm excited to see a
Jets fans of some of the best fans in
the National Football League and I'm
excited to go see them up close and
personal before I go
we have a surprise video
from the bills Mafia tailgate
and I'm excited to see it because we
didn't talk about this before so I'm
excited to see what it is man let me
check it out y'all know about another
signature haircut right yeah
[Applause]
I got the razors right here who wants to
do it
[Applause]
oh
let's go Buffalo
man it's hard man that is hard man
that's super cool man Bill's Mafia man
I've been a part of some some great fan
bases from you know Los Angeles Rams the
the ramley to Broncos country you know
both of those fan bases were quality fan
bases and I loved those guys forever
um but because Mafia is just different
man and you know they go all the way in
man and I love these guys man
um it's not a comparison to any of those
other fan bases they showed me so much
love and I'll always be appreciative to
those fan bases But Bill's Mafia man
they just go all the way out man and
it's super cool and and super dope to be
a part of it man and Shout Out Bill's
Mafia man let's go get this dub let's go
get this Dove Sunday man let's go get
this Dove Sunday for for Bill's Mafia
man this one's for y'all man out coach
Wade Phillips he always told us to
dedicate you know games to people that
you love throughout the season you know
I already dedicated one of my Uncle June
bug our dedicated one to my mom and my
dad and my son
this game right here is for Bill's Mafia
you know our first divisional game
versus the New York Jets at third place
really good Jets team it's not the same
Jets team that we've been used to
playing they're really good
we really good too man and this game is
for Bill's Mafia this week and that's it
man you know I'm gonna sign off you can
catch uh this full episode on the BR app
um you can check out the Bleacher Report
uh YouTube page you know to catch this
show as well or you can just go to
wherever you you like to get your
podcast from you know to catch up with
Devon cash and listen to it it's an
honor the privilege to bring this Von
cash to you each and every Tuesday I
love you guys the DJ sauce money done
I'm out
all right
foreign